la première manifestation elle nous a
paru étonnante parce que c'était une
opération facs mortes
du coup ça nous a en tout cas nous en
histoire intéressé de savoir ce qui se
passait réellement donc on a mené toute
notre petite enquête pour savoir ce qui
se passait et au jour d'aujourd'hui on
s'est retrouvé engagé parce que
ça crée des dysfonctionnements au niveau
des élèves notamment sur les statuts ce
genre de choses on a plein de frein pour
nos études alors les enseignants essaie
de pallier au mieux à ces fera à essayer
de nous faire sortir justement de tous
ces problèmes mais ils sont à bout de
souffle et au jour d'aujourd'hui ils ont
besoin qu'on les aide
et du coup c'est pour ça que nous nous
sommes engagés c'est à dire que ils ont
besoin que les étudiants soit avec eux
et on est avec eux pour justement
réussir à se faire entendre
le poil et le poids des étudiants est
très important parce qu'en fin de compte
si on n'avait pas de professeur si on
avait si on ne soupçonnait pas nos
professeurs on aurait pas de courir
réussirait pas tout simplement